but you told me that you've gone out of
your way to develop new material you've
been practicing at open mics yes yep and
it's it's current material oh yeah just
or you know it might be a some of the
materials a story that's a from the past
but I haven't told it right okay stand
up yeah you talk about getting your dick
ripped off or almost ripped off yeah
yeah
4.5 yeah just the the you know one of
the things I want to talk about there is
just how crazy is to have my dick all
over Netflix this is super weird I was
like you're not supposed to get your
dick out at all in public but you know
there's a close-up so my dick that
everyone can just click on and watch on
Netflix no right
um because I I think of it as you we
were all wearing uh like g g string
underwear but to show the damage that
your dick sister yeah it was out and it
was really like if you had a big screen
TV it'd be about this big right what
would you it was good would you call
that a blood blister
oh my veins just turned black and got
like like balls of black you know like I
guess stuffed up blood or something it
looked bad it looked like something was
gonna burst or my dick would never work
again and it was fine I mean it hurt for
a while but it was fine was that who
else got was it your dick too that got
pulled
fortunately or not fortunately for me
the the weight of the brick and for
anybody who didn't see jackass 4.5
considering how well it performed I
think everybody did everyone but this
was the first thing we filmed for
Jackass forever when we went into
production very first day of like
principal production the first bit we
filmed first thing in the morning 9am
was uh owed to the movie Old School
where they're standing up building and
tie bricks to their wieners and they're
like we're gonna do it for real life you
know we're gonna do it for real I got
like okay man here we go it was funny
too because not everybody some people
were broke for long enough that it would
hit the ground two strings were too
short until you pointed out I didn't
even know that there was like that
obvious I didn't you said oh hey you
know I wonder who it is and I looked
down like oh man but before that I
didn't even really pay enough attention
I'm not I
I can't remember that well because I
think it was really fairly obvious yeah
well in the video it is when I watched
it now I wonder why they didn't just
make everybody's string too short why
save two people hmm good point they
needed some dicks for later
right but but uh famously Dave only has
one ball and so my two balls and shaft
were enough to kind of uh reinforce the
the hold such that my brick broke my
string
wow did we talk about in the last one
why you only have one ball what happened
to it all right we did talk about it
yeah oh okay yeah hernia no more
accidents
I always had the idea that like the
snowboard like sliced your nutsack and
your ball fell out but in fact yeah it
didn't happen on a mountain somewhere
right now it's rolling down the mountain
it's gonna do a snowball and got bigger
and bigger yeah took out a whole family
taking them out now it's called Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on Amazon and type in Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude